voilà bon et puis le roman de colleen
mccullough et alors là aussi il ya une
héroïne je crois qu'on peut pas dire le
contraire
jusqu'à présent il avait d'ailleurs que
des héros de ce que j'ai mis mon logis
plus rien j'ai plus d'oreilles sont peu
me redonner une oreille s'il vous plaît
ça serait bien donc ces honneurs à lang
prix non langtry prénom en aura et là je
vous demandais de sa nationalité et son
âge je vivais mais très vite j'ai plus
d'oreilles c'est qu'il ait commis
longtemps mais voilà on a est tombée
place
nadeau alors à l'étude mais vous pouvez
répondre pendant ce temps un
nationaliste âge de votre héroïne la
gestion stratégique elle aura 31 ans en
novembre